The Joe Rogan Experience did you see the
guy in East Palestine that talks like
Mickey Mouse now yeah I did I was just
swallowing a true brain what's that it's
a nootropic you want to try it yeah
dude was on my podcast once the doctor
and came up with this stuff
orange thing he was a doctor was he a
doctor
I don't want to give anybody extra
titles you want to try one you want to
get smarter no no no I don't wanna stay
where you're at yeah
it doesn't make you smarter helps your
memory a little bit it's good for a
verbal memory
sometimes the Mary Jane [__] with the
mind that's delicious it's good right
it's a nice little liquid
little shot I like it looks like a snow
cone the voice thing wouldn't there be
multiple videos of multiple multiple
people with that it could be his own
reaction to it he got a very high dose
it could be uh there's more people
they're not talking about it because
there's more people more people that's
that's what's what this article says
they're going to go check door to door
hmm oh they're sending the CDC in bro
this is very scary stuff yeah very scary
youngstown's 20 minutes from there and
they just call it East Palestine they
don't say it's 45 minutes away from
Pittsburgh or 45 minutes away from
Cleveland they just call it East
Palestine so it's getting into
Youngstown too oh yeah it's getting in
everywhere right everywhere Pittsburgh's
really close yep Columbus is not far
away that's so scary did you see the
dead deer that they've been finding
this dude uh took video he was down by
the river or this Creek or whatever it
is and it's just [__] completely
polluted you know he saw rocks in it you
see big oil slicks Bowl up and uh he
found three dead deer like really close
to each other it is on the map there's
East Palestine
youngstown's right there dude oh my God
Pittsburgh's right there are those
videos of it raining in Ohio where it
was like foam is that fake I don't know
did you see that snow and all the stuff
in the ground it's like foaming rain bro
what's in those clouds now and that's a
cloudy place they literally have the
lake effect there so the precipitation
that's where it's always Grace cloudy
always oh my God it's sitting above you
yep is it does it dissipate
what happens to the uh this the poison
that gets into the air goes to
Pittsburgh yeah where's it go like if it
really hovers over you like holy [__]
and comes down when it rains what the
[__] the video that I don't know it's
real is show demand outside and when it
was raining it just seemed like it was
Suds and so that's not normal I don't
know if it's a real video it's Tick Tock
but wouldn't you think that whatever the
smoke is like whatever the particles are
they would be too heavy to just sit in
the clouds wouldn't you think that they
would fall to the ground
I don't know we're both we're too stupid
to talk about this what would you Jamie
you're smarter than us what do you think
would happen like if if chemicals were
burned and they went into this into the
clouds would they stay in the clouds I
think back to the movies of like uh the
dirty Waters just came out where they're
looking into like you know chemical
companies and people getting [__] up
and there's giant lawsuits that go on
forever Aaron Brockovich thing I think
was a similar situation people getting
[__] up from some Chemical Company
mm-hmm
why would this one be different honestly
no I think it is I think but what I'm
asking is do you think that um when they
burn the chemicals that they stay in the
clouds does that make any sense I don't
think they're gonna tell us and explain
it to us simple people you know some
people might know what a mad scramble
did you and did you see that people were
trying to blame Trump because of
deregulation but it turns out that
whatever deregulation he passed wouldn't
have applied to this and also wasn't
instituted it never really went through
is that true make sure that's true
what is the question
mark Trump was d-write was Trump era
deregulation responsible
for the crash
because I think it was not I don't know
that I think yeah I heard that it was
about the it was a weird bearing for the
company not the not even the train oh
really that's what I had understood oh
really deregulation was about oh really
was gonna happen anyway remember we
looked up there's like 1700 a year so
the deregulation was just basically like
giving money to the corporations
or letting them pay less money I I
that's I don't know I'm just so like
church says uh Washington Post analysis
so far Trump's rollback of regulations
can't be blamed for the train wreck
there you go and that's Washington Post
so if that's Washington Post see uh NTSB
chair contradicts posts that wrongly
claimed Trump to blame for Ohio train
wreck but that's like a thing that
people do immediately whenever there's
something [__] up they immediately
point at Trump he did it he did it
but when the problem with that is like
when you say he did it a lot of people
here oh he did it and then how many
people hear the follow-up how many
people here are like no he didn't do it
and this is actually what happened I bet
it's probably like 60 40. right yeah I
bet like 40 find out that it wasn't true
this is from article says
calls on Trump to back reversing
deregulation in Wake of age of train
derailment it's they're saying it comes
from this letter
uh well maybe he's correct let's let's
read what he has to say like maybe both
things could be true right what could be
true is that the deregulation is bad and
what also could be true is that Trump
wasn't responsible for this this
particular crash both things can be true
this is one thing he can do to express
it express support for reversing the
deregulation that happened on his watch
I heard him say he had nothing to do
with it even though it was in his
administration so if he had nothing to
do with it and they did it in his
administration against his will maybe he
can come out and say that he supports us
moving in a different direction that
seems very reasonable doesn't it yeah
yeah
uh white houses blame Republican
lawmakers in the Trump Administration
for lacks Railway and environmental
regulations in the aftermath of the
derailment White House has pointed to a
2021 letter from the Republican Senators
uh to the Federal Railroad
Administration urging the agency to
expand the use of automated track
inspection and pointed to a republican
study committee proposal to cut to
Government funding for uh to address
chemical spills
hmm that's a weird way the pro proposal
to cut to government funding I think
it's just a typo there uh additionally
Politico reported the Trump
Administration rolled back several
safety measures for Railways including
regular safety Audits and an obama-era
rule that required faster breaks on
trains carrying flammable materials
[Music]
dude how about the fastest breaks yeah
it's containing flammable materials
how about the fastest [__] breaks you
can make yeah but this that's a true
thing though that this particular uh
rail that that thing happened on was not
set up for transferring hazardous waste
right or hazardous materials uh isn't
that true
I think they're saying that that train
was not set up for having that kind of
stuff on it
it's like bro it can just fall off the
tracks going like 300 miles an hour and
explode like what do you got in there
and you're going to ruin everything
forever all around it like how long
before they cleaned that up oh and now
they're what are they going to do it
yeah so what are they going to do with
this what are they doing with it they're
putting in a landfill in Indiana right
Putnam County landfill great
terrific put it in the earth driving it
across the state if you don't own a
landfill bro you could put anything in
there
pewter's bodies all kinds of [__]
old cocaine like dressers four hours ago
story Ohio toxic train disaster leads to
more concerns in other states while
scientists say chemical tests and East
Palestine are unusually high I mean yeah
you think look at that unusually high
really
what a crazy uh statement unusually high
how about toxic for humans
I mean what happens to those people that
can't move those people that are stuck
there like they can't afford to move
they got nowhere to go that's everybody
there by the way yeah at least it's
going to be really cheap to move them
somewhere else like 550 000 houses
everywhere you know
bro
I mean you got to get those people out
of there yeah
like how how dangerous is it you think
to be there right now is it just
groundwater or is it air
is it everything
[__] man you know how scary that would
be if you were poor and you're stuck in
that spot was that plane crash real that
happened oh yeah yeah you know that spot
that story what happened dude a plane
that was uh headed with isn't that true
I I it seemed yeah I'm trying to double
check oh I want to triple check but I'm
pretty sure there were environmental
yeah five environmental scientists who
died in a plane crash were headed to
East Palestine Ohio it says false five
employees of an environmental consulting
firm died in a plane crash near Little
Rock Arkansas on Wednesday but they were
not traveling to East Palestine where a
Freight Train derailed the employees
were responsible responding to an
unrelated February 20th explosion at a
Metals plant in a Cleveland suburb more
than 60 miles away okay okay so it
wasn't true so yeah so the facts and the
day since the February 23 uh 22nd plane
crash some social media users have
falsely claimed the aircraft was
transporting environmental scientists to
East Palestine where a freight train
derailment earlier in the month prompted
officials to intentionally release and
burn toxic vinyl chloride to avoid the
danger of an uncontrolled blast okay so
it was isn't true
so that there was a plane crash filled
with Scientists but they were going to a
different spill that seems a little
fishy fire five environmental scientists
go into some other thing nobody's heard
of when there's this massive tragedy 60
minutes away and that's probably the
closest major well I guess Pittsburgh is
a more major airport that's closer but
that's well we would have to well first
of all we didn't know these scientists
were going there right so we would have
to assume they've already sent
scientists to East Palestine yeah they
don't have to tell you that they're
doing that right it's not like they make
a press release like we're sending
scientists to find out because then
people want to know like what's the
results
like if the results are unprintable like
if the results are like whole oh my God
like everyone's gonna die like who knows
what the results are and we know that if
it is unprintable they're not going to
tell us anyway so if they assessed
everything if they sent five people to
this other crash
how many they said five thousand years
yeah how many Sunday spouse and they
want to like check for sure they want to
like double and triple check on this one
because this is a doozy people are
calling like an American Chernobyl it's
like this is scary [__] yeah
it's wild that those things happen all
the time we googled it the other day
there's like a thousand derailments a
year
they happen all the time
bro
Brigham sent me a meme that was like if
you want to run a train properly here's
who you should hire and it's that cop
lady that got oh yeah yeah I've seen
those she's in like 10 memes poor gal